NARRATOR: With the Philippines
under Allied control
and the Japanese
Navy in disarray,
the US now has a clear
run to advance on Tokyo.
Ultimately, you can bring
to bear your real advantage,
which is American air power.
NARRATOR: And the US has
devastating new air technology.
The B-29 Superfortress
is the ultimate bomber,
flying at 31,000 feet.
To help identify key
targets in Japan,
the US Air Force turns to a
future president for help,
Captain Ronald Reagan,
and the first motion
picture unit in Hollywood.
The unit supports the
war effort by making
recruitment and training films.
And in 1944, they began
an especially sensitive
project, training
pilots for bombing runs
over mainland Japan.
NARRATOR: Reagan begins
work on the assignment.
It is known as Special
Film Project 152.
It's a top secret thing.
In fact, in his
memoir, Reagan later
compares it as
the kind of secret
that's comparable to
Project Manhattan,
building the atom bomb.
The army first
motion picture unit
would take photographs of war
zones throughout the world,
and that included Tokyo.
From these photographs
and footage,
they built this detailed model
of Tokyo and the approach
to Tokyo.
Pilots who were going to be
staging bombing raids on Tokyo
would basically watch these,
we would call them sort
of simulation films, almost.
And they would say, OK, this
is what the approach to Tokyo
looks like.
RONALD REAGAN: The camera
is now ready to roll.
In effect, the
camera is now a B-29.
NARRATOR: Reagan
voices the film.
RONALD REAGAN: Your
target for this mission
will be the Japan international
Aircraft Company Hiratsuka
Plant, with the
Hiratsuka Navy Arsenal
as a secondary objective.
The mouth of the Sagami
River lies below this island.
Reagan wouldn't provide
visual clues for the bombers.
He would say things like, you're
approaching Honshu Island,
the main island of Japan.
You will see inlets
here, a river here.
RONALD REAGAN: Notice
that the target
is made up of
large, single story
buildings set closely together.
Reagan really
felt that this was
a huge contribution
to the war effort
even though he wasn't
on the battle lines.
But this was it for Reagan,
who didn't have an opportunity
to actually fight in the war.
Special project 152 gave
him a real opportunity
to play an operational part
in the success of the war.
NARRATOR: Ronald Reagan's
work helps the B-29
pilots to target Tokyo.
RONALD REAGAN: Upon
reaching Mount Fuji, alter
course to 94 degrees true.
The target lies beyond--
NARRATOR: With
devastating accuracy.
They have one of the highest
strike rates of the war.